[Music]
many of you are familiar with our
grandma jody we're very close to her we
love her some of you may love her now
after hearing her she's a friend of the
show she is a dear friend of the show
she had not been feeling well not been
doing great and we're happy to report
that she seems to be doing much better
uh she's in very good spirits in order
to keep her spirits lifted and
maintained at a nice grandma jody level
we got her an ipad
and we've been helping her navigate this
technology yeah so we've been trying to
explain things that we all now take for
granted like what an icon is and basic
things things like where the messages
are so today i had to tell her where my
mother had sent her a link to this
singer this church type singer guy dan
shooty shout out he's a great singer
they love him and so our grandmother
called we facetimed and it was
interesting walking her through
how to open up a link on a text message
or to explain what a link was or where
to find a text message but i will say
she is making a lot of promise she is
she's a couple days shy of her her 104th
birthday and
you would think that she's a couple days
shy of her 84th birthday yeah and for a
technology like this
considering
the technology they had when she was
younger she continues to blow me away
speaking of being blown away here's the
show
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
with me as always is christian my
brother co-host thank you long christian
zachary long yeah i wonder if
people know that well the uh
the internet's gonna be a flutter with
that information
it's such a cool name zack it is cool
you know i always really liked i was
never crazy about my first name because
people are always
christian or jewish it was always like
an annoying like bad joke to have to
respond to oh yeah crash i was never
crazy about my name but i loved my
middle name and i loved my initials czl
yeah they're cool initials i like my
middle name
sizzle yeah this sizzle reel you put
this on your sizzle reel it's really
cool it's like saying um it's hard to
say it though without it's like
a twigs flick twigs because frika twigs
how do you say that or or somebody said
it's fka you have to say each letter i
think people who know her just call her
twigs
yeah i would imagine or people who are
fans probably just call her twix dude
they don't say twigs you don't think i
don't know don't think
think we continue to um show our story i
know speaking of showing uh their age
our grandmother has you're right she's
been making such great promise that
progress uh she's very promising when it
comes to technology and these brand new
things like in her world
you know she had just figured out the
dvd player she's still by the way
getting netflix dvds sent i didn't know
they did that anymore
i didn't either um but she is now uh
making promise with this ipad and
speaking of promising women
uh promising relatively young women
grandma jody is
young compared to 105 year old yes
that's true and the those the people who
are in the guinness book who are like
100 and aren't there like 120 year old
what is the i don't know
i thought it was um like in the 100
teens is the oldest i think 116. here's
what i wonder because both of our
grandma i don't know if people know this
both of our grandmothers are 103. uh
grandma jody's a couple months older
than our grandma lorraine but
i wonder what that record is for the
oldest living grand mother's hair of
grandma yeah the women in our family
really hang on
the men on the other hand no
unfortunately for us yes that's true and
we are technically men technically uh
for now um but i i i sometimes when i
tell people that my i have two
grandmothers who are 103
uh i think they were like of course
amazed they have that reaction whoa and
then i like to say yeah and they've been
together actually uh for over 70 years i
make it sound like they're a couple no
you do i never heard you make that [ __ ]
oh really i've done it that's funny and
disturbing
yeah it's only by the way we should
clarify it's not disturbing the idea of
two women that age being together is in
no way disturbing not at all it's
because you know those women so well yes
and you know that um they're our
grandmother yeah and it conjures certain
yeah yeah no no no okay so um
but uh
but no they are not they are separate
they've had husbands who have passed
away unfortunately and um
but they're still doing it 103. it's
great and people i we mentioned it
because people who have heard her on the
show and we hope to get her back on the
show uh
they they inquire about her because i
think she's she's awfully lovable yeah
she sure is and um as we said in terms
of the ipad
promising she's a promising young
relative to 105 years so why are we
talking about promising young women well
our guest today is stars in a movie
called a promising promising not a
promising promising young woman
it is
great and our guest today i would say is
even greater than the movie itself wow
our guest is allison brie uh someone
i've known of for a long time i've
always i've enjoyed her work for many
years but i
i've been thinking about this i'm such a
bad memory but i don't think we'd ever
met
and as she would have said i think i'm
good to see you again yeah or she
probably is guessing she has a better
memory when did we meet or where
something yeah or maybe not maybe i'm
flattering myself that i should be so
memorable but um to my knowledge we
haven't met and i've been a fan of hers
for a long time so i i was excited to
get to talk to her what have you liked
her
well i you know community was something
that i really say that again
you're an [ __ ]
uh no i won't because know she was on a
show with joel mchale called well it was
about a college it was about a um a
two-year college i believe oh a
community college yeah yeah that type of
college and um
she is i just recently watched that to
because we had joel on the show and
she's great on that show but i you know
i had seen her mad men yeah i didn't
watch a lot of mad men did you i watched
some of it i've seen a lot of mad men in
my life yes and you know john hamm i do
know john hampton john maybe your guest
of the show by the way shout out very
sad news uh speaking of john and what i
think of jon hamm what do you think of i
mean just besides maybe his handsome
face yeah okay besides certain
anatomical truths about him i think
about where i'd run into him which was
this great bar yeah
it's sad to say that in the past tense
yeah lapu bell is a bar on uh franklin
village many of you may be closing it is
closing officially yeah so
there is a kickstarter campaign i think
that francois started i i kicked in some
just because got all the great times
we've had there i feel like it was the
least we could do yeah we'd see him
there a lot yeah uh man that's that but
um
anyway john no you think of i think of
uh
advertising that world i never really
got into that show of course i know it's
incredible when i think of allison brie
i first saw her in scream four
and she played this very
up this very charactery part and she was
great and i've seen her since in other
things she's always different um
and certainly well she's an actress
that's true she's yeah i guess that's
her job uh-huh she's good at her job
she's uh also in glo yep i'm sorry on
glo with your friend betty maybe future
guest of the show hopefully hello betty
gilpin yeah betty uh
well i'm sure we'll be on the show uh
she's one of the funniest human beings
i've ever met and
i understand now why betty and alison
became friends they're well well now i'm
itching to hear hear this talk well why
don't we just do it why do we why am i
talking i don't know uh here is my
meeting well that makes it sound formal
and not very fun a meeting my zoom
meeting
this is my introduction
to um someone i've admired for a long
time
allison brie life could be a dream
sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
and i also want to tell you that i like
the podcast very much it's been like a
i've been really listening to like every
episode oh my god
that's so nice allison that is so nice
it's so funny when people say
that um
i'm usually not good with compliments i
wonder how you are as with acting stuff
if i love
[Laughter]
the them the merrier even if they're
phony
just bring them on
uh i'm like thank you what else like
what else
no are you are you okay with them can
you you could you like them
i actually i was sort of joking but i
actually am i think very good at taking
compliments i only have realized it
since talking to a lot of people that
fee or listening to podcasts where
people always talk about how they're
uncomfortable everyone i know taking
compliments and i'm like
i guess i'm just fine with it i know
what does that mean about it kind of
makes me feel good well as it should i
don't think it makes me any less
egocentric if anything
there's ego involved in not being able
to take it like that for some reason i
you know what i mean like it to even
make a big deal about it like the false
humility of like no no no no the one
time that i've ever done that is like i
would put it in one of my top regrets of
my lifetime
and maybe this is why i'm okay with
taking compliments for glo i was at the
sag awards and i was nominated and the
show was nominated but none of us won so
we were already like past you know all
of our categories had been announced and
we hadn't wanted so i was like had had a
drink this is maybe a little stoned dave
my husband was with me we saw friends
that were sitting at the three
billboards table
and so we go over and this is a name
droppy story but only to talk about my
humiliation which clearly has been on my
mind ever since i have to get it out of
my system um
so we go over and francis mcdormand is
like
she turns to me and later marin told me
that marc maron who was on the flow with
me told me that she had also told him
how much she loved the show and loved
him and they had this great conversation
with me she turns to me and she goes you
and i was like stoned and like i'm like
she's one of my favorite all the time
like if it's
women who influenced my career you know
like i was like
you yeah and she was like no you and i
was like no you
and then i did that like two more times
to the point that she made a face to me
like all right you win
and then i just was like i'm so sorry
she was just kind of like i love the
show and then kind of left and i was
like
everyone okay wait what were you
supposed to have done you're this is
like an iconic like you said somebody
that you revere
and she's
addressing you in a really uh flattering
kind of over that also just to say you
it doesn't leave a lot of room to
respond and you is a good response
no you
i feel like if i had done one no you and
then just like let her speed maybe
perhaps like
a more cohesive maybe compliment would
have unfolded i could have graciously
said like thank you so much i'm actually
such a huge fan of yours and you're
you're so amazing in this movie that
you'll win an oscar for next week and
yeah but like but don't you think like
people like i would think i mean just to
i'm not saying this to make you feel
better but somebody
like francis mcdormand i would imagine
that to her
is a perfectly normal interaction like i
don't think she is
thinking about it i don't mean that
she's not thinking about you or like
that she's not
impressed by you but that i think to her
was probably like oh that was
if anything that was kind of like
mundane and totally normal you know
she just strikes me as that kind of
person i hope so that eventually she was
just like all right i haven't had enough
of this bit good to see you and i was
like okay and then just for the rest of
my life i'll be like i ruined it
i'm not good with around like famous
people
it's like i want to tell the
them how much i admire then i also don't
want to know it sounds so lame i know
like you want to play it cool you want
to but then you want to give respect you
want to give props like i know it's a
very strange and i guess everyone's
different but uh
i'm always afraid of turning somebody
off somebody like that you know if it's
a work situation and i'm shooting with
someone that's like oh which has only
happened a handful of times i think one
i want to give them their space like i'm
like
don't crowd them
be cool they're at work yeah and you're
at work
but then also i'm like is it are they
thinking it's weird that i never told
them
let's just get really into it who is on
the list of people that you
have felt that way around that you
didn't know how to navigate working with
because they were like
the best well i mean
ready get ready for this bomb i'm going
to draw
um i did work with meryl streep oh no
way and steven spielberg and i played
meryl streep's daughter in this movie
the post oh yeah that's right
oh you're great of course
yes yes
holy [ __ ]
so like but but like i didn't i mean i
feel way weirder about the francis
mcdormand well yeah like i had a great
time
working with merrell and like i
definitely felt
like
she was so lovely to me and but that was
really like she's playing katherine
graham a real person yeah drama like i
definitely felt like know your place
don't talk too much to meryl like even
though she was so lovely
but i was i could feel myself like
normally on set i'm like
and like
i feel like on that side i was like i'm
a serious actor
ready ready set and ready for action
well also spielberg i mean like being
around being i can't imagine being
around him you want to be like okay i'm
here to work weirdly i felt so
comfortable with spielberg and he
treated me like a daughter and i was
like asking him questions constantly i
feel like i was so much more comfortable
i really wanted to be respectful and
give meryl her space and then
spielberg's who's directing the movie
i'm like between takes i'd just be with
him like so what are you how are you
setting up the shot oh why no kidding
and he was like he loved it he'd be like
oh well you know i'm really going to try
to establish a different aesthetic from
the office scenes and the home scene oh
you know the way that wow
it was wow it was
incredible but in the scenes at like i
don't want to i want to just be clear
that like meryl wasn't making me
uncomfortable or anything like that but
i realized right away that like i didn't
know what to say to her and i nev and i
definitely never was like
i'm a huge fan like
later i was like i wonder if she knows
does she know oh no so you never even
got
you never even got to say anything
remotely like that like it was a you're
such a wow no kidding the funniest thing
to me was like one of my first
conversations well the first time i met
her was i was on set i was there just
for a costume fitting and i wasn't
shooting and
stephen was like come sit behind the
monitor and watch this take
i watched meryl streep like do this
scene
where she's like it was an emotional
scene it was so and then i watched so
i'm sitting i haven't even started
shooting yet oh my god behind steven
spielberg watching merrell on the screen
and spielberg is turning around to me
being like whoa
could you believe what she just did
oh my god i would any we become so
self-conscious of
everything i was doing of where my hands
were
how i was react i'd be so self-conscious
to be in that environment
so then i just felt like so everyone
sort of had like a whole merrell kind of
yeah yeah yeah
and then well okay so here's the funny
thing i was going to say is my first day
shooting i got to set
and the hair stylist kind of was giving
me a little trim and was saying like oh
wow look you were you know we're all
playing real people and it's a period
piece and she was like you're actually
your hair is already kind of the length
of the woman that you're playing and
you're actually probably going to be the
only person in the movie who's not
wearing a wig and i was like oh that's
great and she says to me like
do you wear a lot of wigs do you like
wearing wigs and i remember thinking
like what a weird dumb like i don't want
to have a conversation about that i was
like i don't know no
then i get to set and i'm sitting next
to meryl streep
and there's just a lull and i was like
oh you're the wig like it looks so great
you um do you like wearing wigs
and meryl was like
sleep
meryl streep is like
i mean i don't know i wear them so often
like this was like
totally i totally i meant to get a glass
of water
then i settled in and more would ask her
like what she was doing for the weekend
and so i thought
we and we would look through the like on
set magazines that were all period
appropriate and comment on like the
clothing so we i settled in a little bit
you settled in i only shot a handful of
days so there wasn't like it wasn't like
a brother-daughter road trip movie with
me and merrell where we're like yeah
yeah you're really bonding i'm sure
she's also used to that first couple of
days or hours or however long it is
where people are just like
being [ __ ] weird around her i'm sure
she's just like used to it i mean the
good news is that like i think it's so
not even about that like that the wig
story is lame but like ultimately it was
about like holding my own in the scene
yeah just being good and you're great in
the movie thank you there it is
that was a long way for a compliment you
really do
move on from this story
he was not taking the bait
uh but but it it must be i also think
somebody who is such an actor i mean
what they do is that such a big part of
what who they are and what they do that
if they if you match them in a scene if
you're able to if they're able to play
with you effectively in a scene like
that's where the respect is earned you
know and and
totally you did that so you must feel
good about that well and i do think
i i i do think i'm good at reading a
room so like i definitely well without
compromising myself or like totally
changing who i am as a person i would
say that like
on a comedy set
i'm different than on maybe a drama set
like read the room yeah yeah and also i
feel like i'm different
if i you know like if i'm on the set of
glow and i'm number one on the call
sheet i'm different on set than if i'm
numbered of course
you come in like guns blazing hey
everybody
yeah i know i'm getting texts from betty
i'm looking down because i asked betty
gilpin if there were any funny stories
that i should bring up or embarrassing
are you good friends with bed really
good friends yeah and i've not known oh
my god i guess i'm not back i guess she
doesn't consider us very good friends if
she hasn't
she's texting you currently i'm waiting
for uh actually i'm not waiting for a
response we finished our correspondence
yeah because she hasn't been out there
no but we stay inside we talk
we pretty much talk every day oh really
oh that's great i love her so i mean i
don't have to tell you then
how great she is she and she said oh man
i love her so much
ask her about the time
she peed her pants no i'm kidding
um she said nothing i can think of that
isn't locked in the vault oh that's nice
we talk every single day you do talk
every day you will love her ah that's
awesome she's probably the most
comfortable in her own skin person i've
ever met
wow oh my gosh what a glowing review
yeah
i love that oh i'm obsessed with betty i
do have peeing my pants stories but we
don't i feel like i've talked to people
before but when you first said that i
was like oh yeah i used to do that
really truly in my mind i was like it
was more combing like have i ever done
which one betty or is she just thinking
of a story i told her
about another time when i did it
that's funny what
like fully peed like saturated i mean on
mad men once there was a there was a
peeing incident but which i've talked
about before but it's like uh
because we wore girdles like uh which
you probably don't fully understand what
a girdle is but it's like it's basically
like biker shorts that go all the way
then up to your like ribs
and it's like a control top period like
not like a time period appropriate
so then there's a small hole in them so
that you don't have to because you're
really like bound then they connect to
stockings and all that stuff so but i so
i didn't know for the first season of
mad men that you really weren't supposed
to wear underwear under them because
they are
underwear but i was like trying to
respect the wardrobe and was just like
that feels gross so
i had underwear
and i was rushing to set and i went to i
was like i have to go to the bathroom
but talk about i mean in terms of what
we're just like mad men was like my
first job so
like my first real job so like i didn't
ever want to be the problem person like
even having to go to the bathroom on the
way to set even if i've been waiting in
my trailer for four hours like they need
you now i'm like oh i have to pay i'm so
sorry
i know that panic i know it so well
yeah so rushed to the bathroom tried to
like pull the hole open but i didn't
pull my underwear
to the side so i'm peeing and i'm like
not hearing it hit the bowl
and then i just feel warmth i just feel
like oh god it's crazy
i know that and it was a
full pee because i thought oh gonna pee
in the toilet it usually is quickly
followed by a sense of relief
and then to have the relief immediately
yeah dread relief into dread it's really
funny
and then i just how can i ask you how
long
you were doing it before you noticed
that it wasn't hitting the the water the
bowl i mean probably half of the pee and
i have like real legit full p's like
like what full five seconds i thought
you were gonna ask how long did i go
until i like
changed out of my pee underwear which is
probably several takes oh you went back
in the under with you did you have to
yeah i went straight to set i was like i
cannot i've just taken
five minutes to go pee i just dabbed it
with a bunch of toilet paper
oh my god yeah i know
i was like
they're waiting for you
they're waiting on me yeah i'm not
allowed to see that person here again
number 22
someone a madman i'm a recurring guest
star
i don't want to lose my job so i go we
do several takes
and finally
they're turning the camera around and
our costume designer jamie bryant who
was like the best came over and was like
you look amazing and i was sort of like
thanks
and she was like what's wrong but no i
want to tell you also that the skirt i
was wearing was a big a-line dress so
it's not like uh-huh
it wasn't like seeping through my
costume or anything
i'm picturing a puddle on the floor
there wasn't that i should know she was
like what's wrong and i just was like
i peed
feeding
she was like
it wouldn't be the first time i'll bring
one i'll bring one up here she couldn't
have been better about that were you
your parents were in the business no
well
you know
my not my
um my mother definitely not my mother's
worked in education my whole life sort
of in different facets and but mostly um
administration
and early child development programs
which i think made her a great mom
my dad was a singer
is a singer-songwriter guitarist and
when i was really little like until i
was
five
and before that was a living in
hollywood playing music like trying to
make it as a musician and made a living
like playing at restaurants was like the
music in the night like uh yeah the
music this is the music the music
that's so cool so he was like but like a
singer like a folksy james taylor kind
of guy
yes it was like he was writing his yes
exactly and kind of writing his own
music but also
playing covers you know if he's like the
in-house uh entertainment like a bar
band like a bar or a restaurant yeah and
and in hollywood so he has a lot of
stories about like you know meeting like
robin williams or meeting like tom
selleck maybe not tom selleck but like
people like that um i just was watching
three men and a baby and then three men
and a little lady so i have time oh you
saw back to back my mind we had a couple
days in between we're like a little ways
into three men a little lady i didn't
think my husband was gonna like let us
roll into the second one but then last
night he was like we can put it on for a
little while you've earned it
uh
you know i've never seen the second one
uh how is it you love him you've never
seen either i i've seen the first i've
seen three men and a baby but i think
once she became a little lady i was like
well how's this gonna work it was fun
seeing them take care of this infant
well you know what i was going to just
say you're wrong you should watch the
second one but i have yet to really see
how well it's going to hold up like also
the both of these hold a lot of
nostalgia for me
they were definitely big like cable
movies that were on hbo when i was a kid
and i watched it so many times that i
love yeah but
the second movie is worth watching just
for
oh god i'm not i can't think of her name
the the british actress who is on
killing eve did you ever did you watch
that she's like
a very famous but she's the older like
uh
people listening to this are gonna be
like you idiot how disrespectful well
it's also the woman who direct didn't
the woman who direct your
yes
yes emerald the best name i've ever
emerald fennel
i know a great name but it might be
sanel i'm not sure oh
shoot okay well well i hope it's fennel
i've been saying fennel for a year and
uh two days ago on a zoom uh press thing
that we were all doing together the guy
kept saying finnell and i was like oh oh
really oh that's funny wait um oh [ __ ] i
really want to know this oh let me look
it up i have a phone right here oh my
god we have this technology no no no you
don't you look it up because you're not
going to know
the right woman you know what i mean
well what if i just look up the whole
cast oh fiona shaw is it fiona yes fiona
oh okay yeah
okay
now we're back on track three-member
little lady is worth watching just for
fiona shaw's performance in which she
plays the school master at this boarding
school that the daughter is going to get
sent to who's like
always coming on to tom selleck
you can just look up clips of her on
youtube okay because she like
does this thing with her she's always
like putting her hand under her shirt
she's like so overwhelmed like she's so
horny for him in the movie she can't
even like not like touch her like neck
and breast while she talks to him it's
so great life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
oh my gosh i'm oh i have a buddy here
oh no allison's holding up a cat with us
oh i don't mean to laugh at you sir
that flea collar it's not a flea collar
you are not a cat person and no one
that's come on this podcast is a cat
person sorry so you do listen
so yeah
wait what is it tone it's a cone odie
otis got neutered two days ago oh
so he's got a cone on and his soda so he
doesn't lick it
so he doesn't lick his balls and and
make the incision worse but
his former balls that's right well he
still has a sack i was reading a lot
about it this morning where they just
make an incision and like suck out the
balls and then they leave the sack oh
buddy he's been we're recording right
michelle because i don't i'm gonna need
you to say that again if we're not i
said that to my husband yesterday after
i learned it and he and he just goes now
i just picture the vet like
like oh he's like slurping
like an oyster
oh man i don't think that's how they do
it i don't think that i think they use
like tools i hope
it depends on where you go
it depends on what country we couldn't
go inside so i'll never know i'll never
know
it was behind closed doors oh my god
they slurp it out how old is otis he's
about six months so we have two kittens
otis and maxine who's a girl max and uh
so i feel like i should say because
you know in the animal world
people get very uh people are very
sensitive about like animal stuff and
yes some people felt like we didn't get
them spayed and neutered soon enough oh
oh you mean like people on social media
or something well i told a story on
gordon about how odie was peeing on his
balls
this is good that i don't have kids or
just cats because clearly nothing is
sacred
but he couldn't stop peeing on his balls
and then like making little pee ball
like splotches around the house so after
i told the p ball story on corydon my
mom calls me and is like my friend who
works at this rescue is is furious and
she's very worried about your cats and
they should have if they are five months
old they really should have already been
neutered and spayed and i will say we
were worried it was going to get a
little dicey because we have a male and
a female so it's like you don't want
them to have sex with each other you
know what i mean but i do want to just
say that our vet which is a new vet that
we're going to they wouldn't allow us i
did try to make a spay and neuter
appointment for them months ago but they
don't do it before they're six months
old so that's why we had to work and
also they have to be like a certain
weight it's a pretty intense surgery for
the girls so the place that my mom's
friend works at a rescue place where
they do it on all the kitties at two
months old
and what what inspired you to get the
cats
in the first place well
we had had two uh two cats for a long
time so when i met dave when i met dave
he oh my god this guy's really rolling
around and now he's caught on my sword
you're okay so this is otis
like
since odie lost his balls he's like
really in touch with his feminine side
he's been such
[Laughter]
have you noticed really a difference in
his behavior he's not as aggressive they
both he was never aggressive i would say
they both were super sweet like lab
kitties even before before two days ago
but
truly in the last couple days otis is
like
even with the cone on he's so sweet and
it's so funny he when he wants love he
comes over and he's just purring and
purring and he just like rides around
and then you start petting him and then
he just collapses his full weight into
your arm he's really he's really cute
i'm looking at him right now what would
you call what kind of cat is it like a
brindley it's a it's a tabby they're
brown tabbies but they're they were
they're rescue cats so they're kind of
we don't really know who the dad was the
mother was a black cat
a black alley cat have you seen this
thing on otis yet where they're like
because i've had dogs who've been
neutered and occasionally they'll get um
like phantom balls like the the sack
fills up
with these two
do you know what i'm talking about it's
like
this is interesting and then it and it
sort of allows me to kind of
finish what i was going to say which is
that when i met dave he had two male
cats that were like 15 pounds brothers
his brothers so dave's brother adopted
kittens and then dave lived with him for
a while and then he moved out and like
took the kittens was like these are my
kids like i spent more time with them
than you took the kids by the time we
met there are two 15 pound you know
eight-year-old cats 15 pounds cheese
they were big boys and they were
brothers and their balls i always would
be like did your brother get these guys
neutered because and he was like i'm
sure he did and i'd be like it just
looks like they have balls
i know i'd like pokemon and be like you
seem like
legit
i know i know what you mean
in a non-sexual way i i assumed that
but also how do you poke a ball in a
sexual way that's not a
much of a sexual move to just
actually
i stand corrected okay i'm sorry i
shouldn't have been a human ball
sexually
it must be so
i feel very comfortable with you now so
i i i can reveal how weird i think it
must be for you guys
to have to deal with those things in any
romantic in any
any
romantic way
i just don't know how i i i don't i
don't know how you do it uh balls to me
are just so weird and i have them oh
you're saying you don't know how women
deal i was like
i was like i wasn't understanding i was
like sorry are you concerned about me
poking my cat's balls it's not something
i have to do no i know you're just
curious
it's a choice
yeah it's uh
the phantom balls thing really it really
makes me laugh and i i want there must
be a
i bet people will write in you know i
encourage people to write in and let us
know about what it fills with
what does it fill with
um
that women have to deal with guys having
balls that's what you were saying yeah
sure yeah i was fascinated by balls i
like
i loved when when boyfriends
you know in high school i'd be like let
me really like look at your balls i've
got a little self-conscious about it
yeah an ex-girlfriend of mine used to be
i remember she used to just she played
with them in a way that was like um it
was not at all
it was like
this is gonna i don't know how it was
like examining yeah yeah like whoa she'd
be like well this whoa and can i do this
i she used to like push the limits of
like what she was fascinated by them and
and which i get like if i
i
i i would be too if i didn't have if i
haven't been you know with them for so
long kind of like guys and boobs boobs
yeah sure some degree but but different
because
it's true that the texture of a ball of
a testicle and like the outer skin and
the inner ball like it you're right for
women it's sort of what is this thing i
bet it must be so mysterious and and
there's no way to know how sensitive
they are but they're also that must be a
weird component for you guys like that
they're that side
like a testing of like how much could i
stretch the yes
yes guys they don't love that the
stretch test i call it the breeze
stretch test
i don't love it
oh i've heard of that in fact that was
the next question i had um
okay uh we covered the ball stuff uh how
weird your testicles are okay uh
but you um i i do want to get to it's
actually not a bad pivot for the movie
for a promising young woman i i don't
disagree uh the movie is so i don't know
how to like encapsulate it because i i
feel like it'd be kind of belittling to
it to call it like a revenge
fantasy or whatever but i've heard it
described that way it is i know it's
tough because i feel like it's also the
kind of movie where you don't want to
give a lot away because even in the
first scene of the movie i feel like
there's like you think it's gonna go one
way and then it goes another way
it definitely is a revenge thriller i
would say with like uh with dark comedic
aspects yeah this woman it's about
really like rape culture and um what i
found fascinating about it was they they
examine a side of it that i think
really deserves to be
examined and amplified which is that
in some of these cases a lot of the
arguments that are supportive of the
male of the men's behavior are
completely debunked let's say and
because a lot of the characters use
those arguments that i've heard in the
past which is like uh
well she was drunk and she was in she
put herself in that situation you know
um it makes such a great the way they
make a case against all of those
arguments is so [ __ ] good effect oh
definitely i think it's such a brilliant
movie first of all because it's really
entertaining like you're reading the
script it was so unexpected so for like
such a dark
subject matter it like looks really
colorful and yummy and it's like all
like pop music paris hilton totally
the music is great yeah yeah it's sort
of like like bubblegum
yes it's like we're smuggling like
this important message or important not
message but like themes important like
conversations to be had but yeah it's
like a trojan horse kind of wrapped in
this like delicious yummy like
jawbreaker bubblegum yes totally like a
unicorn uh toy or something um she has a
scene at carrie mulligan is [ __ ]
great yeah everyone is like you the
acting you guys are
everyone is so god oh [ __ ] bo burnham
ah he's great
he's great but like it also works on on
that level as a romantic comedy it's
like one of the best i've seen totally
it makes a switch where you're like oh
it's going to be this true again the
movie just it's like i don't want to
keep saying it because then you're
waiting for unexpected things to happen
but i will say that i think the movie is
very unexpected
i know you don't want to rate i know you
don't want to like set too high the
expectations that build up like yeah i'm
waiting to be wait for the reveal
i guess
but don't be but don't expect it but
you'll be unexpected um right but yeah i
know
no i do think it's it's in terms of what
you were saying
i was excited about the role that i got
to play because i think that what
emeralds done really well also is not
make it a binary issue like it's not
uh men or villains and women are victims
she also there's my character and also
um uh connie britton
like the dean of the college and both of
us sort of really represent the female
side of
victim blaming that were the women who
were saying those same things we were
all doing that we were just having fun
boys
like
and then when carrie turns it around on
you guys and and forces you to see it in
a way that is personal yeah um and and
that's when it really hits home for both
those characters i wrote that i love
this line when she says to connie
britton i guess it feels different when
it's someone you love
um without giving anything away she
turns around on connie and
makes her see it that way she does the
same to your character
um what what how how what was that like
getting in because you get to play two
you get to play that character on two
totally different um ends of that
spectrum
yeah how did you go about that you know
it is a movie about accountability right
like as a society i don't think that
even carrie
her character who's on this revenge
mission
really just wants people to take
responsibility and acknowledge what was
happening you know it's sort of like in
this moment that we're currently having
a same societal reckoning with that kind
of stuff and it's like yeah
you see even as men get called out
some are like
wow i apologize i didn't real like a
genuine i didn't realize and i now that
i see it i can't unsee it and i will
change my behavior and others who are
just like i don't see the problem the
worst one is the i i'm sorry you feel
that way but
infuriating don't say anything i'd
rather not hear anything than um
than that yeah uh and and carrie's
character like you said wants
wants to he wants to be heard wants to
be seen wants acknowledgement for what
happened um i've gotten to do a couple
press things over zoom with everybody
and hearing emerald talk about it she
she did put it in this great way where
she was like every character in the
movie actually has
there are these like escape doors that
they could go out if they would respond
appropriately to what kerry is asking of
them but they never do like i know i
know it's true there are certain things
that that um would be so easily resolved
if if it were just acknowledged and a
genuine like you said a genuine opponent
i'm sorry yeah it goes such a long way
it's it's uh the older i get the more
the clear that becomes you know oh
absolutely i hasn't this whole year i
feel like this whole year has been
eye-opening for me in terms of that
about all different sort of subject
matters of me being like
wow i really didn't know that that was
shitty maybe
yeah there's something i could do
differently
yeah
i know i didn't know that's where you
were coming from just acknowledging
other people's yeah i love the message i
just love the way it's done though god
is it [ __ ] like you said it's and
it's funny and it's entertaining it's
well that's also i think it's like you
know i mean obviously every type of
movie it's important that movies are
made in all different tones and all that
kind of stuff but
i hate when something feels like it's
hammering a message home
or it's like preachy and this is not
that at all i think it's like really fun
and it almost gets you laughing in
certain scenarios where you're like
should i be laughing
i know and then when you stop laughing
it's so much more effective suddenly the
silence is making your brain move in a
different way and process things in a
different way and you're like yes it
like coaxes you it like comforts you
with this kind of fun tone
and then it gets [ __ ] gets dark and yes
yeah
shivs
yeah let's put that up that's a good for
the poster
um
it just shifts you unexpectedly really
comfortable and then you're gonna get
[ __ ]
yeah get ready for your a good
old-fashioned soul shiven
what i'll say about shooting it just but
i'll be brief but because it kind of
goes along with the things we were
talking about that this was one of those
jobs where
i think i shot three days i mean the
coal shoot was like 23 days and carrie
was in every scene and everyone else is
in about one or two scenes except for bo
bo burnham right but like
i think it attracted a great cast
because the script was so cool and the
way emerald even talked about the movie
it was just like i mean the product is
even better than what i expected but
like every step of the way it was like i
read the script and it was like so cool
and different then i talked to emerald
about it it was even better um and also
the way it's written each character
really has something to do with carrie
mulligan like you're really you're not
just popping in for a day to say three
lines and you're walking by in the
background it's like a teta tete every
scene yeah that alfred it's funny that
alfred molina was in because it reminded
me his thing was like his scene in
boogie nights and
every one of you guys have those like
rich
they're small parts but they're really
yeah intrinsic my scene in the
restaurant with carrie mulligan was the
very first scene that they shot for the
whole movie you're kidding you're
kidding
talking about like coming in with that
confidence or whatever it was really
like a funny day on set where i was like
i realized this is all about carrie and
this movie is this whole thing but today
like
i'm fine i'm just i know but it was like
today it's a two-hander between the two
of us and like it is gotta
be there you know yeah weird that was
the first day at bed i bet you guys are
both
and you get to be drunk and
uh you're both so good at that uh it's
just fun watching two really good
actresses be um drunk like carrie's
incred that factor is actually really
heavily into the movie is her performing
drunk as that um her character pretends
to be drunk many times to like
solicit these douchey
toxic men it's [ __ ]
you're so good everyone's so good i'm
going to talk more about it in the intro
um
in outro but but um i want to get to the
lightning round
um so excited this is our last episode
of the year
dare i say the finale episode you can
say it yeah dare i say grand finale
by the way do you have plans for new
year's eve do i have a pit stain in this
armpit uh yeah but so what i would
actually no i actually don't oh i do but
do you know what oh do you yeah i can't
tell if this is new or old this
sweatshirt is like one of my costumes
from glow that my wardrobe lady let me
keep what if this is like an old no it's
got it oh i'm sweating i'm sweating
talking to you well it's it's intense
it's an intense conversation sorry do we
have plans then you get that ring
yeah uh
we're gonna have to wash it yeah it's
good it's really like legit 80s where
are you exactly it's so beautiful behind
you there's there's a lot of um foliage
yeah i'm at home
uh-huh is that the out the yard is that
no it's actually like a great ruse it's
sort of just like the entry walkway to
get your house but it's all bamboo that
like blocks between us and our
neighbor's house so this is like the
weirdest corner like the majority of my
house is out that way but behind it's
like a good little zoom nook because it
looks like yes we live in a lush jungle
it it does it really does um do people
point it out a lot are you sick of
having to be like nah
yeah no actually i like it because for
the first half of the year i've done a
surprising amount of zoom press this
year during quarantine and we used to
have a different position
where we were by like a wall in like
this painting and i feel like and then
everyone was commenting on the painting
which was fine because it was my
grandfather's painting but like cool
then i switched areas so i'm glad it was
good to have positive reinforcement like
people like the new background uh-huh
okay because that's right it's really
working
the zoom room but that's allison you did
they've directed or did you direct that
movie that dave dave yeah dave did it
yeah
the rental with jeremy white uh
gentlemen white buddy of mine uh i i
gotta see that i heard it's great oh
great you'll love it it's so good i want
i said i was like that's lame to say as
an actor in the movie but as a proud
wife
of course
it's not like
wow that's so cool how long have you
guys been married now
um in february we will have been married
for four years together for nine years
wow
together eight years
nine years
jesus and and uh all with cats every
year
every year with cats we've got we went
about one month without cats
from when our cat harry died uh earlier
this year to uh to me being like we got
to get kittens
oh man and never thought of any getting
dogs huh we're not not dog people now
okay all right uh well we've covered
that that's one of the lightning
questions um
sorry do you have new year's plans what
are you gonna do
no
i mean we were gonna i don't think we're
gonna do anything
okay
well why why i mean your family's there
and
you got dave and the cats
um
well
okay if i'm being totally honest i think
we might well my birthday is um on the
29th
so we usually leave town because it's
like not a great uh birthday
it's nice
yeah
yeah so you know to like uh assuage my
depression we i like to like i don't
know if persuasion applies to depression
or only guilt but in this context yeah
i think it does that's a good question
uh yeah make it better make your
depression better right we we
we usually leave town so like with covet
and everything you know because
otherwise it's like it feels
we're in that weird dead zone but it's
actually yeah we can always leave town
because neither we're never working you
know the whole everything shuts down so
we usually go to town we did book a
hotel room close by like an hour drive
away so we might still try to do that
just the two of us for my birthday
through new year's
that's
yeah you know i have the same thing i i
get um and it's been getting
a little worse every year just that that
birthday
depression is
is it
fear of just
losing time is it just getting closer
not to be morbid but is it like no i
have no fear of death and i've so far i
don't mind getting older it's mostly
just like my friends are not in town and
uh okay
okay
yeah me too
sorry
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
[Music]
uh here we go your most what's your most
commonly used emoji would you say oh
yeah um i really like the like brunette
in a purple shirt i was shrugging like
this i don't know yeah yeah for sure you
know yeah this is basically how i feel
about everything in my life oh i just
did this but yeah
it comes in handy yeah
um that's very useful i i do i guess i
do that i've been doing that a lot the
brunette boy
or man now that's isn't that that's
telling that i consider it a boy when i
use it in my text
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play
okay i think if like i snap my fingers
and suddenly i have like new skills
i think i would say gymnastics like an
olympic gymnast but if i had to go more
practically i would say probably
wrestler because i've done some training
you must be pretty good now i mean i
that's what you guys trained
constantly right yes we really did but
and
we did retain a lot of it absolutely i
feel like there's so much muscle memory
there and a lot of it too just has to do
with
so much that we learned about
balance and stuff like that but also
um just overcoming fear so like that's
the setback every season is being like
oh yeah so for that move i just fully
dived forward
head first into this other person and i
believe that they're going to catch me
cool okay okay
oh my god oh my god
was jesus chris you did it for three
years it was three yes well four because
we actually started shooting the fourth
season so i shot a huge wrestling match
in the fourth season that no one will
ever see with some magical pro wrestlers
no kidding
yeah
how many episodes in were you guys just
two they we
would shot a full first episode and then
half of the second episode and now oh oh
so it was right before quarantine then
yes we started at the top of march and
then and we all got shut down and and
now it's gone forever it got cancelled
sorry sorry
that's so surprising because i i've only
heard
and i love the show but i
i heard it was doing well i just assumed
it was doing well it was like i know i
think the covet of it all it became
really difficult to say how and when we
could feasibly go back for something
that's so physical i don't yeah i also
don't know how they measure all that
stuff i had a show on netflix that just
got cancelled i was like oh really i
thought
i don't know
such a surprise and it was like there
was no i know it's a bummer but it's a
bummer um
[Music]
very first world problems hard to
exactly publicly depressed about it um
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life uh what would it be
okay you seem excited i'm very excited
i've been thinking about this constantly
i have to tell you that it's like i feel
like i'm cheating a little with the
lightning round because i listen to your
podcast a lot and so like as i'm
listening to it every time i'm like in
my head changing my lightning round
answers oh it's like i'm doing the
lightning round all the time
um
so that's funny i feel like for snack
food i have to do like if we were not in
quarantine it would be probably just raw
cashews and that's a boring answer but
in quarantine my my to be honest i would
say
i've been in a real uh chip phase and
like but like uh like gluten-free
tortilla chip alternatives so like give
me like a coconut chip have you seen
those like or like a um
i love these like rice chips that are
flavored like um
sesame and seaweed little nori yes yes
yes i know exactly what you're talking
about this is so i wish i didn't
um
what are those what are these um coconut
chips they're like i want to say like
penums or like
they're like crunchy like paying or
penang
yes those are great for dessert but then
they have a savory one but not by the
same company that's like
in a pink bag it's like you know they're
seasoned with little himalayan sea salts
i'm just such a [ __ ]
whole foods ship aisle
me too i'm so into this um
there's a new pirate's booty makes a new
puff
have you have you seen this are you are
you aware of this i haven't there's oh
it's incredible i can't stop i just love
the guys it's all the things i always
just like to laugh at being like it's
the healthy um yes i'm eating a large
bag of chips in one sitting but they're
healthy because it's coconut it's
coconuts but i know i've been doing that
i do get when you get stoned are you
really do you get really snacky because
i heard there's a strain i i gotta get
this weed that's not as snacky i um i've
been seeking it out too because yeah
i've heard about it quite a bit so i
have to bring that stuff in i like to
kind of like plan the snack ahead of
time so you don't go overboard like when
you yeah yeah like i bought the snack
and i'm probably gonna eat this snack
and that's fine we're all finished with
the snack we're good what's yeah i
should do that i but not i do the same
thing with these like
healthy chips at whole foods and
they're a huge bag it's like i look at
the fat content i'm like oh well it's
only like three or four percent but
you'll look at the calories and be like
it's not bad and then you'll be like how
many servings are in the bag and it's
like fine
oh yeah i've been doing like what's nine
times five
i guess i had half my saturated fat
um
what is when you're stoned what kind of
movies do you like what like what kind
of stuff do you like watching what's
your oh
um
like planet earth
yeah or like
paddington to any sequel
well that's one of our because you
listen to the show you know that like i
one the question one of the questions
we're gonna get rid of is what's your
favorite movie of all time this is just
too hard for yeah
well now that it's still 20 20 what is
your favorite movie i'm glad you asked
it is definitively the american
president
starring annette benning
for real yes
oh whoa oh and michael douglas
and michael j fox what a great way to
my hero that's my i'm so glad that you
know the movie i don't know i can't i
might have no
sense rob reiner oh yeah it is and
sorkin
wrote it
that's right that's right i gotta i
gotta re-watch it it's
been allison just showed off just showed
up for pitts thing or was that a
triumphant judd nelson
no it was just a pit stain it was like
okay [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i gotta just you
know
just i've ever
please the american president please
please please
we have i have pl by the way i have
plenty of time i'll just fly i just want
to say
that i've probably watched it i mean
hundreds of times i will watch it if
davey leaves town i'll i'll put it on
every night like to go to sleep like oh
wow but the weird thing which i kind of
wasn't sure if this even was like i kind
of was like maybe i'm over it now i've
watched it so many times like has it
lost its
zing
and then the other day davey got home
and he walks in and it's on like it's
like midday it's on
in the living room and he's like i was
like it just was on i was flipping
through channels it was just on and he
was like
he was like at this point
it's actually impressive like your
ability to always watch this movie
yeah impressive
yeah and during the date the american
pres american president during the day
any time oh i love it so much what is it
allison about what because i don't i'm
not that familiar with the movie what is
it about it that that is such a so
appealing that it's it's a good question
i would say
solid writing it's like such it really
is a feel-good movie and it's sort of
like
still in that era of like those good
romantic comedies where there was like
really good acting really great
performances but still like
quintessential romantic comedy moments
like he's gonna you know he's like wants
to go see her at the end and he's trying
to gather all
his things and at the last second he
turns and she comes flying in the door
and like yeah i cry every time like and
annette benning i think she has all
these great little because they're both
such great dramatic actors she has all
these little great comedic moments you
know there's like a moment that i just
always love where she's tapping her pen
and she's in a meeting and it's before
her first date with the president of the
united states which used to be the big
deal
oh yeah remember that yeah i know
michael douglas um it's also like
watching the west wing where you're like
it's this imaginary world where the
president is like this amazing moral
person
like
um yeah and then it humanizes him and
he's going on a date and it's like the
president goes on dates weird yeah and
anyway the guy's like what do you have a
hot date and then she like goes to put
her pen down and spills the cup of pens
which like would read as a kooky broad
moment but it's not at all
no because she's commit she's so
committed she's like that in american
beauty too she has moments that are so
big quote unquote but they're [ __ ]
real um i swear i'm not blowing smoke i
fee you do that i feel like you have
moments like that oh my god
that can be big and charactery but
always real always
grounded yeah
and
now i'm thinking about the movie because
i just saw it but carrie and bo burnham
in that pharmacy during that
getting to know you montage yeah singing
periscope it's
amazing but there's both anyway they're
so good uh i'm gonna rewatch that i i
really um you've inspired me annette
benning's shoulders when she's dancing
with michael douglas in her strapless
blue ball gown oh man
i'm so glad i what a great way to retire
that question
if you had to live somewhere else
where would it be i think
i think portland oregon oh that's where
you guys shot
dave's movie yes and so i'm sure i mean
most of the movie we were actually
outside of portland in this small town
called banden on the coast it was like
four hours from portland but oh on the
coast i'd love to go to the i've never
been to the coast it just was i'm sure
that i'm conflating it with that
experience because it was all just such
a great time
and like yeah i've never felt more in
love i loved watching dave like come
into his like as a journalist he was
such a good director we had our kids
it's very attractive it was very
attractive and yeah harry was with him
not that he needs
any help
being a treasure
yeah um but like it was such a nice we
had this great i mean for a movie that's
about like a horror movie about airbnb's
we actually have this great little
airbnb just like tiny cabin but on the
beach and we had we've never
i mean it's our first time well it's not
our that's a lie we've we've done on
location together before but it was the
first time we had brought our cat so it
really felt like we were home i don't
know when i loved it and we finished the
shoot in portland for like a week and
i've been there once one other time and
i just
really loved it there
if you could have dinner with with three
people dead or alive you've never met
this is the toughest one i'm changing
that though are you changing my life
yeah yeah i was just getting a little
cool and i wanted to just
like give so funny myself back to life
this is when i wish it were uh
videotaped but um
i love that they're like nice subtle
degrees of coloring on you and you like
and this is what happens when i turn off
my light
i just dark or ominous
i'm gonna put some chopsticks
yeah oh nice what's what flavor
chapstick oh this is just carmex oh
carmex okay that's a real dave thing but
he buys them in bulk so then i use them
i'm full of looks
for myself because i'm just looking so
dead i realize it's a podcast but look
the listeners need to know oh no you
look great you no uh you think you look
dead i think i look a little bit like a
corpse
like to stop like not a zom not the
undead just oh right not like rotting
no no not rotting not really rising
like recently passed away
kind of like i'm dead and i'm like in my
casket and my family was like don't put
too much makeup on her we want her to
look natural
do you want to be would you rather be
barry or do you want to be buried no no
i should probably like i don't know
cremate me or pre-made of science i'm
not sure i know i have a will somewhere
but i don't know what it says i forget i
i don't think i do i got to get on that
you you you'd want to be donated to
science i mean who cares
yeah that's true that's true maybe take
it dad
yeah
but maybe it's more for the people who
are still alive right so you're sort of
like maybe that may be donating it's
like could be kind of morbid for
your survival kids or something relative
yeah
yeah to run into you at like in like a
science lab her eyes looked just like my
mother's eyes
are those
right
what um i had read now i'm so curious
about everything you you had said
somewhere you don't want to have kids
right no not really yeah
is that that's okay that's
it i
whenever i know you never know right
right like
um
it's not strange of course but um
i whenever i meet somebody that i
like and you're both such like
impressive people to me that
i would think just like self like
selfishly for the world i think oh
that's a shame because
you guys
should procreate for the you know it'd
be good to have more of the two of you
around in the world like i appreciate
that as a sentiment okay okay okay
what you think about it if that changes
your mind at all
me wanting you guys to progress um but
also you have three nephews so that must
be like so you get plenty of
i love having that and being able to
give them back
oh yeah it's the best i was on facetime
with one of my nephews yesterday for 20
minutes talking about foxes
oh
i'm jealous that's the best and then i
was like i gotta go i gotta take a
shower like i'm so i'm kind of over this
conversation now
and you get impressive that you went
yeah oh the kids are so good at getting
off the phone that's impressive to me oh
definitely he was like great i wanted to
go first
uh how do you talk about what what was
the bulk of the fox conversation
the bulk of the conversation well he had
got he wanted to show me a new stuffed
animal he got that was a fox that he
named foxy but then he wanted to show me
on his computer the different foxes so
we could decide which one looked the
most like foxy his toy oh okay and then
we got on a weird tangent where there
were like some weird like or like baby
foxes that looked kind of gross
i don't know
how old is he he's uh
six
there's three of them three of them
they're seven and six and four but the
oldest one is turning eight uh in like a
few days so i was trying to like oh
dude wow yeah and how you have one
sibling yeah just an older sister my
older sister yeah
oh that's good what does she do
she you know now she's just uh
really just being a mom but she was
she's three kids yeah she was a
financial advisor for years and she does
sort of still she kind of still helps
with handling
that's great oh my god you're so lucky
those are things that i mean i love kids
and i would like to have good but jesus
finances and business and that you get
to
oh that's way better i mean
i love my nephews but i also get extreme
anxiety
talking about financial stuff so it's
really yeah nice to have my sister help
me with that oh
very lucky um okay okay i gotta hurry
i'm sorry yeah okay i'm so sorry uh okay
three people dead or alive whom you've
never met oh yeah okay okay i'm gonna
say the cast of nine to five
um dolly parton
and james no no no gene how dare you oh
my god sorry sorry i'm sorry the the
caveat is
that i have met jane fonda
twice but i don't think she would
remember we didn't really okay once i
did a table read with her for some
random movie that i don't think ever got
made but it was truly just like hello
miss fonda and then oh yeah um
and then once i did like a weird
um photo shoot friend it was like for
it must have been for some like new york
magazine or something but it was for
netflix so it was me
jane fonda
jason bateman
um laverne cox and
um robin wright i was just like
wow yeah all right all together yeah
just all of us together like we're like
lying we're like lying on a
bed like we're not lying on a bed weird
there's like a white background we're
all like lying on it it was very strange
but i was like glow's gonna be a hit and
then they were like get cancelled
[Laughter]
oh that was recently no no i was like it
was like it was like when the first
season i think had just come out
okay okay um but still i think those
ladies would be a blast to have dinner
with and just let us
just hear this want to hear all the
stories
who's your favorite muppet i'm i'm
guessing you love the muppets oh sure no
oh no because we
no that's okay we changed it to uh your
favorite simpsons character so this
could be a little teaser for the new new
year's questions
well i mean look i love the i like the
muppets a good amount i love kermit so
boring sometimes people will branch into
sesame street even though i'm like does
that count i would say it's not
fallopigus i was like a big
snuff oh yeah
girl yes i loved his eyelashes yeah
i remember how
fluffy um
okay all right the character on the
simpsons who's in love with lisa in that
one episode oh mom more is it martin
martin i just i just peed my plans
tonight they're like go apple go orange
and he's like go banana and it's like
yeah
yes yeah i think it's martin
uh
i think um okay it sound right it
doesn't sound right it doesn't does it
lisa i choose you choose you yes that's
the one yes yes
um if you were to be one age this is
also
i i don't like just asking we got rid of
this because when you ask a young person
this it's like my age
yeah i know
truly
if you had to be one age for the rest of
your life what would you pick i mean
like 35
allison i swear to god i thought you
were 30 years old i swear to god oh
thank you i thought you
if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you pick
house cats
in our household because they have great
lives
second second answer giraffe
favorite favorite animal would you
rather be called um unattractive or
unfunny
i mean probably probably unfunny like in
my heart of hearts
i really appreciate that honestly i
think it's very impressive yeah
i i i think i would too i think i would
too your episode with lake bell and the
way she talked about it i was like yeah
of course
like for now that's the answer but like
one day yeah you gotta pivot
yeah yeah well that's gross that's gross
um something to aspire to uh which oh
that's gross i thought you said that's
gross i was like it's true
it's gross
it's i said it with a lisp uh
which which golden girl do you most
identify with dorothy by the way i've
been watching the i don't know when the
last time you saw the golden girls
blanche pragmatic you said it like
blanche too and now you're making a
blanche face uh dogs or cats we know the
answer to this yep uh the beatles are
the rolling stones beetles uh all the
way would you have a favorite song um
julia
is my oh i love that song half of what i
have of what i said john lennon is
trying to say that he wrote it about his
mother
oh really i think i i thought i read
that somewhere and if and if i am wrong
then skewer me in the comments okay and
god i hope john lennon's not listening
um wherever he is uh i hope none of the
beatles are listening frankly um i hope
chocolate candy i hope one of you
it'd be nice one out of two would be
nice
uh the chocolate candy or fruity candy
your stone you get you have a sweet
tooth i know i and i do and i would say
i flip i pretty much flip back and forth
but if i had to choose one i would say
chocolate because probably all-time
candy for me is uh peanut m ms christian
as well oh
this is perfect yeah he said it checks
all the boxes that it's that desert
island candy for him
absolutely and if you went fruity and
you were you tore into a bag of skittles
uh what would be your order um
orange
and then like the rest in a handful oh
wow orange orange is that much wow uh
okay fascinating um allison how do you
want to be remembered uh we're gonna ask
this this way in the new year what is an
adjective what what's the one adjective
that you would
you would hope people choose to describe
you
after afterwards when you're
in a um in a science lab somewhere um
kind
so boring
not
that's the thing right i think about
this sometimes because we're actors so
we make work but like sometimes i'll
think about like
what what's the lifespan of like tv
versus movies or you know when you do
certain projects sometimes it's
interesting which ones
like like how much you love doing
something has no bearing on
how lasting of effect or if it will at
all will anything sometimes it's like
the inverse you know
and yeah and sometimes i'll think oh
maybe i don't have a fear of death or
maybe i don't want to have kids because
it's like i have this legacy of things
that i've already made but then i'll be
like i doubt that anything i've made is
going to stand the test of like in
50 years i don't know that anyone would
be watching anything that i've made but
like i think if you treat people well
and they like you know glean from you
like oh you know what i could be i could
be pretty i could be pretty good at this
and be like treat people kindly
compassionately
that's that would be the thing i i
completely agree and that's one of the
things that i i think has always
appealed to me about acting on
on the screen because
there's that degree of permanence so it
feels like well something's gonna
survive i don't know how for how long
yeah um
but but yeah there's something
comforting in that uh
i i i'm sorry that this went so long i'm
sorry i just love talking to you this
has been so fun
i know you do um
thank you though for for indulging thank
you for having me oh i can't wait to
call betty or text her and tell her i'm
uh i
she's been listening to this i have run
speaker and she hasn't said anything yes
um you are awesome this has been so fun
thank you for having me
thank you for doing it um and uh and
we'll it'll come out on your birthday
whoa
happy birthday to you what a gift
well that
such an affable way of speaking like to
tone towards kent cummins
yeah
it is
maybe two of you listening will get that
reference maybe kent cummings was a
stylist for an ex-girlfriend of mine
we've talked about him we have right
okay it was drew's stylist yeah we've
said we talked about him he is
and he sounded like this oh jl
where's your brother doggy they would
call druid can't we call christian doggy
it's such a like
um melodious tone melodious
the leslie uh yeah she does have a bit
of that in her oh it's like oh there's
she's very like joyful sounding yes yeah
very happy like blithe yeah oh wow
thanks yeah cool uh and like betty said
she's the most comfortable person in her
own skin and i i think i understand
exactly what she means she seems
extremely comfortable which is good
which is why when you're speaking to
somebody like that when i am i don't
want to speak for everyone else it's i
am so it's so easy to engage with people
like that because
you feel comfortable you guys really had
a nice rapport i could have done that
for another
what hour and a half it's surprising
when someone you've never met you just i
know click with like that's rare that's
right it because a lot of it is the
quality that you just articulated in her
which is she is so comfortable so people
like that then
put you at ease make you comfortable to
say certain things right it means you
don't have to do as much work it's like
right have you ever been on a date where
the person you're on the date with is
shy or not a great talker for whatever
reason
and you have to do all the
conversational heavy lifting yeah being
on a date with her i imagine would be
the exact opposite where
it would be fun but you wouldn't there'd
be no pressure on you to keep the
conversation afloat it'd be like one of
those dates where the waiter or waitress
comes over and says uh you've had you
finished your dessert like you know an
hour ago and they're like
anything else they want to bring the
bill they kind of want to like move the
tables and get people out of there you
know my friend liz and i used to go to
the diner late at night and we would
stay and talk for so long that
eventually the staff would bring us
little like cookies and rugelach and
we'd call them goodbye desserts
it was their way of saying you've been
here for three and a half hours it's
funny it's time to go yeah that's such a
nice goodbye desserts
pennies are athena athena
shout out well no longer in existence it
doesn't no no it's it's still a diner
but it's no longer oh yeah well that's
funny yeah you would need i bet you'd
get good by desserts on a date yeah i
don't want to say date she's married i
mean yeah to dave frank dave also very
handsome yeah an impressive man i've
heard he's such a nice guy to work with
and such i really like him as an actor
too just the two of them that's what i
said when i told them they should
procreate speak oh yeah speaking of the
franco brothers when she was talking
about her love cats and the franco
brothers love of cats and they had a
disagreement about who's going to keep
these kittens
i would it made me think i would give
anything to be a fly on the wall
watching the franco brothers argue about
who's keeping a cat
it's such a funny idea to me i know you
know i'm surprised because james does so
much with like you know he does so many
experimental type shorts i'm surprised
they didn't film that what a good
opportunity to make like a little
documentary i know about the fight over
these cats and also 15 pounds for a cat
isn't that really big i think it's like
a lion i am allergic to cats i don't
know if i told allison this i don't
think you did yeah because who cares
it's also she likes cats
i can't be around them i know but i do
like cats that's the thing i'm always
conflicted because i like touching them
petting them and i when she was
describing
hers in the way it would flop down that
sounded nice to me but i just know that
you know i get hiv did it sound nice to
you when she was talking about sucking
out
his balls you know what sounded it was
nice to be able to talk about that with
a stranger with somebody i just met yeah
it was fun in a situation like this i
have to kind of rely on them
especially when it's a woman to push the
boundaries you know to like set the goal
posts and
and she just kept moving them in a great
way where it's like oh wow that makes
you feel comfortable to say to say
something like i don't know how you guys
deal with balls
well that's what i was like after i said
well i guess he's comfortable with this
new person
after i said that there was like i don't
know if you registered this there was a
slight pause and i started getting a
little penny like pull up pull up it
wasn't the time it was too much too soon
but then she picked it up she went back
to it in fact right she went back to it
and picked it up and was like you know i
don't mind balls and started talking
about her fast because i but you know
again betty's like that and for betty to
have
signed off or validated um
her in that way it makes sense because
betty you can talk i can talk to betty
about balls all day also i kind of agree
with you that i mean obviously i don't
not obviously but i don't enjoy um
other people's balls but
but i would also that's not obvious
by the way sometimes on the show it's
really not obvious no i know i know but
i don't uh
but i think
most women i've talked to about balls
in my life
for the most part they say it's
something they
deal with it's like it's part of the
body yeah it's is obviously they're not
disgusted by them and again
this is a generalization but i from what
i've heard it's balls are like a thing
that's there that they're not grossed
out by but they're not like
craving you know what i mean
i
many women do or men do yes yes but i
get what my point is i get when you say
i don't know how women deal with them it
makes some sense to me because even
women who are attracted to men or men
who are attracted to men for the most
part aren't like into ball yeah like and
again like you said this is purely
anecdotal i just imagine some people
listening and hearing like
two men i hope my grandmother's not
listening
i hope she doesn't figure out the
podcast app mom yesterday was like she's
like explain to her about your she kept
calling it your ipod tell her about your
ipod she tried that with me too and i
was like ah
yeah
like she heard her episode and she liked
it yeah that's good enough for me i
don't need to try to hear this for
example right um but yeah i just imagine
two people hopefully not a grandmother
listening
maybe other grandmothers listening to
two men
like ex mansplain how women
feel about paul it's ridiculous that's
ridiculous but um yeah but anecdotally
like you i i've the times that i have
talked to women
in my life about boss this isn't the
response usually like yeah they're fun
they're neither here nor there or it
ranges from occasionally it's like
sometimes i like
to like oh yeah i kind of like just deal
with them they're like in the way it's
usually in that window
and that window is indifferent yeah the
ball window yeah as someone who has them
i don't derive all that whatever it's
not the most pleasurable
area yes it's very sensitive too
i know you're telling me like i don't
know i know i know but allison get but
she got it she got it she got it and the
wheat then the skin and then she started
talking about playing with them and i
started thinking about like
all the things you can do with like
puppetry the penis speaking of balls
she listens to the podcast how nice is
that very flattering how cool i mean to
the point and other people have said
that too but
this was the first time that i like
genuinely
believed the person because
she when we got the lightning round when
you got the lightning round she was like
oh i feel like i'm cheating because she
knew all the questions to the point
where she had already formulated a lot
of her answers and that's never happened
with a guest good answers too and yeah i
you know we've talked about that like is
that a good thing or not whether or not
that's helpful if somebody is very
familiar and there's an argument to be
made that they work better if it's just
like nature right well also we're going
to be in a couple weeks we're going to
be changing some of them out for some
new ones yeah but i was going to say i
like i liked how
contemplative she was about yes and how
much she thought especially like i agree
with a lot of them yeah right choices
oh you like the i like that i
she likes alternative chips
too yeah you don't both have like
alternative kids from hopefully nothing
well the chip that i forgot to mention
that i love tarot yeah yeah i think you
did mention it
i thought
you know what i think i said it out loud
when we were listening to it afterwards
i was like oh tara why don't i talk
about my love of terror you know what a
good ship is uh trader joe's makes this
yeah it's a truffle potato chip oh yeah
really [ __ ] up the i was kicking
myself about the where you're probably
gonna
chide me shine me for it
did you know what i'm gonna say about
the simpsons yeah about you didn't
remember ralph's name yeah ralph wiggum
i choo choo choose you i was kicking
myself afterwards because he it's one of
my favorite characters too and i
remembered it when um oh i interviewed i
don't want to spoil it because i'm
learning
but a future guess the show was talking
about his love gave it away it's a man
uh his love of chief wiggum and he does
an incredible impression of chief oh
really yeah chief wiggum's son israel oh
yeah yeah so here's my boy but i i don't
think it's a
terrible mistake to confuse ralph with
martin with martin i mean there are his
classmates they're both like doughy 10
year old boys they're
they're not that different they're both
kind of the big difference is martin is
very intelligent and ralph is the
opposite that's that's that's the key
difference yeah yeah yeah because uh
ralph is the kid who like i like when he
eats paste he's like i found some i
found some food in the food bin uh-huh
uh she's a blanche that makes sense and
i said i also [ __ ] up there i was like
right because we were you know sometimes
this happens where there's a publicist
who is giving me
uh instructions to move it along a
little bit and
allison's a perfect example of this i
was so engaged in the conversation i so
enjoyed talking to her that i just
wasn't as aware as i should have been
about the time so i was getting these
little like messages like hurried along
so by that point when she said she
clearly said blanche and i was like
right and for some reason i thought she
said dorothy so i was like right the
pragmatic one pragmatic yes but she she
is she seems like a blanche she loves
peanut m ms and she's 100 correct she
must be so fun to go to out to a bar
with yeah she seems like a really fun
person to hang with it'd be great to
work with her because i think like such
a big part of working on movies for me
personally
is um you know is the hanging out is the
socializing element and
she is
such a good actress god is she good in
this movie
i can't wait for you to see this movie
promise i want to see it i just saw the
trailer it looks really good oh it's so
good god damn and that guy beau burnham
is great and you should read this letter
oh yeah okay
uh it's from whoa
whoa
i want to spell this name well just have
you here
guess how to say it
k-e-r-r-i-a-n-n
carrie anne yeah i've never seen that
carrie anne
um carrying my way i have you have we uh
worked with the carrie anne we did yes
in uh not in town
not recently oh okay a couple years ago
oh yes
i remember yeah who has also worked at
that restaurant yeah yeah very nice she
was really helpful
uh but it didn't spell it this way it's
interesting spelling carrying anyway we
can cut all that did you know we were
gonna cut is that yeah that looks oh i
think we should keep that that's gold
carrie
i'm carrying on subject shrimp taco with
tough hot sauce recipe and would you
rather oh yeah a shrimp taco
tough recipe great oh
hi justin christian first off long time
listener love the podcast it gets me
through my long days working as a
chemist especially through this pandemic
it's very nice i love the episode with
david cross i was laughing so much as i
was working my co-workers probably think
i am insane
i in parentheses i wear headphones and
listen
it'd be funny to just as a chemist just
see this canvas like start laughing
randomly you don't see the headphones
i heard the new promotion you both are
doing about tough hot sauce
and great sponsor and
it's she says tough but it's tough it is
trustworthy
i'm like right for the record i'm like
ron burgundy just read what's on the
teleprompter i heard the new promotion
you both are doing about
trough hot sauce and i know how much you
justin love tacos so i attach my shrimp
taco recipe oh great
i have where i make a black
truffle trough hot sauce crema to top
the tacos trough shrimp taco sounds
really good so good cooking and baking
has really helped me as well during this
time i'm currently pretending i'm on
masterchef and trying to impress gordon
ramsay
hopefully you will try it and love it i
will try it
and hopefully love it my husband and i
play would you rather during long car
rides to massachusetts hey when we visit
his family as he is from there and now
displaced in maryland
that is a long car right i thought maybe
these couple would be interesting for
you and christian great thanks carrion
all right number one would you rather
have to walk through 100 small spider
webs with no spiders but there are bees
or walk through one very big spider web
with a very big spider with no bees
100 small spider webs no i i have my
answer
um
are there bees in the web is that what
she means
is the one big spider uh dangerous
speak that's what i was thinking because
you know the ones that i was the
specific situation that i've been in
that reminds me of this
the latter part of her would you rather
there's in florida there's a type of
spider called i think it's the bananas i
mean in any tropical environment they
live in i think the banana spider and in
florida they when i was doing
[ __ ] scraps
japanese crap is down there um
i they were everywhere i remember this
one day in particular we're shooting in
these beautiful old like spanish moss
everywhere these remote locations and
there were these massive webs i mean
they were
god they must have been like six feet by
six feet you know they were like that
big and and when the light would hit
them a certain way you could see the
whole thing was so cool and often in the
middle there would be this massive
banana spider but i don't think they
were they're toxic so it's all right
well for the sake of the hypothetical
let's say
that cushions rolling wrong
that was such an unnecessary tangent
let's say it's uh well i'm thinking you
need to have a visual the bees and the
spider in both scenarios are not
dangerous particularly they're just
creepy or whatever
i uh am more
get uh creeped out by i don't really
care about the um webs that doesn't
bother me yeah it's the spider i dislike
bees more than the spider so you would
pick the big spider going i'd pick the
big spider big spider weight me too
me too
yeah with the caveat of if the spider is
poisonous obviously i picked the beast
yeah unless the bees are dangerous
that's confusing we need more clarity
yeah okay is there another one yeah two
would you rather have long
now i really hope graham is not
listening would you rather have long
fart stream little boy coming out of you
all the time that smells slightly all
the time yeah just like an open faucet
yeah like you're bleeding the radiators
okay by the way that was my chair
or only fart once a year
but it's
super loud
and always happens in a crowded place
and smells of cookies
cookies cookies
and then in parentheses of course my
husband asked me this one he loves his
toilet humor what is up with that up in
new england none of my guy friends in
maryland are like that none of her guy
friends like toilet humor
uh well
the way she set it up it's lawrence just
broke wind it's it's so obvious you
would pick the the cookie one but but if
we were to amend the hypothetical i
would say
let's make the second option one really
loud really awful smelling yeah one that
that happens at the most um
like when you're surrounded by
the most uh i don't know how you say it
um the highest situation of your year
where you're like around your boss who
would that be for you like if you were
around
i mean for me it'd be like let's say i
anything on a date with somebody you
really like or something okay
um
for you or yeah or like i said you mean
larry david
no that wouldn't no no because he'd be
like he'd laugh about it i'm trying to
think of a scenario um it'd be in public
it'd be like other people witnessing
maybe at like uh uh my nephew's
christening or something
that'd be so funny something like that
and it was awful and loud
or a continuous stream i i think i would
still pick even in that case i would
still pick the one loud because i
wouldn't want like a continuous stream
all the time me too who does that remind
you of by the way continuous stream
where it slightly smells i don't know oh
you maybe didn't have her i had a
teacher oh right and i don't want to say
her name obviously it's embarrassing but
i did have a teacher who had it in issue
gastrointestinal issue and she gave a
speech in the beginning of the year she
was just basically like just so you know
get it she had a southern accent she was
like i have an issue and she described
it and she was like very upfront about
it and i just i passed gas i passed gas
uh fair you know regularly and i think
it was pretty constant and she said so i
want you all to get your laughs out of
the way right now but see often and
constant are two different things
like farting every nine seconds is
different than never not farting
that's true you know
like you said it's it's like a leak it's
just like
and that would be
tough and
yeah and slightly smelling i mean even
slightly smaller yeah i would get out of
the way do one big thing and by the way
once a year
if that's all it is and it might and
also probably be funny
it'd probably be something probably
definitely be something that you could
eventually the only reason i wouldn't
pick that is if i somehow became the
chief justice of the supreme court and i
was swearing in a president at the
inauguration
and i farted on live national television
into the microphone in front of all the
dignitaries see but i'm still this is
selfish then i would do one long stream
i know but selfishly
i would i would like to see that i mean
i would uh oh for me to do yeah it's not
that's not the question
you want
no i know you would pick for me
i know you picked the most embarrassing
place you know togo just sent me a
really funny video of a woman on like
tick tock like i'm never gonna get on
tick tock mark my words but okay i do
like looking at if somebody sends me a
video from it or something and there was
a woman
who was described it's so weird to
explain but she was showing off her
suv her truck that she tricked out in um
do you know jojo siwa yes i do
like this grown woman she's got this
showing off this truck that has jojo
siwa plastered all over this thing and
she's like and this is my joe and joe
joe see what hood am i jojo she was
steering wheel and all that and at one
point she just goes
and she's like okay that was me i farted
okay i farted so back to the truck and
she keeps going on the truck but the
fart i was thinking about this far why
it was so funny
obviously because she's like showing off
this thing it was just like sidetracked
her for a second but the fart itself
that to me is the funniest type of fart
the one that it's like the rudy giuliani
part you've told me about that and i
even i can't believe oh it's really
funny is it like that it's like it's
during one of those hearings that
they're having yeah
and it just sidetracked him for half a
second
the funniest post fart reaction is to
try to not react that's my favorite
reaction i hope in 2021 i continue to
find farts funny i think i will and uh
how could you not especially a part like
that i gotta see the giuliani one but
the one where it's like it just sneaks
out it's like uh
it
it's like they're escaping it's like
they're they're making a run for it you
know
is that the end of the letter oh sorry
sorry okay back to carry on thank you
for all the entertainment and the laughs
you have provided during this time let
me know if you like the recipe also
congratulations to christian and maggie
on their engagement oh there's an
explanation point so i read it okay
thank you kerry i wish you guys a
lifetime of happiness carrie anne
patrick ps hopefully this isn't too long
also a huge fan of all your movies and
shorts ah thanks carrie that's that's a
nice really nice where is the recipe by
the way um
oh okay cool uh we should definitely try
that oh man trough shout out love the
trough um
thanks here what a great we'd like
clarity on some of those things
also good for future uh if you'd like to
write in yeah our email address is life
is short at wondering.com and uh we're
very appreciative to have to have had
allison brie who is oh yeah extremely
what a change impressive
what a funny
gem what a gem that dave franco
lucky guy he knows what's he what he
knows what he's doing he knows he knows
what he's doing maybe future guests the
show also lucky allison i'm sure yeah
two of them uh must be fun to hang out
with and so yeah it'd be great to get
him on the show
uh any franco um who's the franco
pitcher for the mets
john frank sean franco yeah
uh anyway
thank you everyone who's listening all
the franco's
the francophiles
and we hope elsa is a real francophone
and we hope that you uh all have a happy
and healthy new year and we'll see you
very soon and may old acquaintances be
forgotten what
community hey i said it maybe that's the
secret to saying community you have to
say after you [ __ ] up with word you go
right into it
yes anyway thank you to the life of
short community
good job thank you thanks for listening
and we will talk to you next year
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted and produced by you
christian law it's also produced by
megan monaco and our senior producer on
this one is michelle miesh
there's an audio engineer his name is
sergio enriquez and speaking of sergio
the executive producers are marshall
louie and hernan lopez for wondering
bye happy new year see you next year do
you like that joke i love it
[Music]
let me keep this photo the photo's
ridiculous are you an organ donor it
might what an
organ donor
wants my 102 year old organs
i don't know maybe your organs are
pretty good they've they're well they've
blessed you yeah
you're like a honda civic
right now yeah yeah that's i don't think
they want that
so your hip but they say it's still good
really well that's what you said you
think my liver and my kidneys are so
good you're alive
been working are you an organ yeah
that's what i decided to
yeah what do i want with that if
anything happens oh god well you know
have you decided yet what's gonna happen
to us after we close our eyes for the
last time no i haven't decided
i can't make up my mind yet maybe that's
why i can't die oh really i don't know
what's gonna happen to me